all right i'm gonna go ahead and start
the recording now
and starting in five
four three two
i thank you very much for joining this
session today
uh i'm nandani krishnamurti um i lead
the applications development for
instructor
i'm very excited to talk to you about
inscriptor's cutting edge
onyx platform biology has
unlimited potential to positively change
the world
we firmly believe this at inscriptor and
many of you are harnessing the power of
biology daily as part of your work
and what we want to do is build better
tools for you
that will accelerate your success
so we've developed the onyx platform a
cohesive ecosystem
that has software instrument consumables
assays that scales the microbial
genome engineering this platform helps
you make
custom libraries of genome edited cells
with push button simplicity in this talk
i will cover
how the technology enables you and what
applications
you can use it for we all appreciate the
powerful foundations that drive biology
one the ability to detect phenotypic
variation
selecting for preferred phenotypes and
the identification of genotypes
that cause the phenotypic variation for
centuries biologists relied on evolution
by sampling natural variation in
populations and making inferences of
genotype to phenotype relationships
the power of this approach is
demonstrated in modern agriculture of
course with both
breeding of crops and livestock
we've been using mutagenesis to create
variation
and that has led to a lot of discoveries
in several model organisms
and more recently we do have seen
advances in directed evolution of
proteins
that even got france's arnold her nobel
prize
but as powerful as these approaches are
they have
a few limitations for instance
once an interesting phenotype is
identified
figuring out the genotype that actually
causes this phenotype from the genome
is pretty daunting and
there is no control over the type or
location of this variation
and these limitations mean that there
are
very long cycles of learning
many of these limitations are driven
by deficiencies in our technology
while it is commonplace to be able to
create
variation across the genome
even with precise genome editing
technologies like crispr
one is typically limited by the type of
variation that can be created
for instance predominantly what we
create
are genome-wide knockout libraries how
do we open up
other regulatory aspects in biology
conversely when making a large variety
of edit types
we are usually limited in the number of
genomic locations
accessible in an experiment so this is
what we show in the x and y
axis here and to this you can add
additional challenges
like slow laborious workflows
and long cycles of learning so
to truly advance biology
we need to get into this upper right
quadrant that is we need to be able to
generate a variety of edit types
across the genome with speed
reliability and ease
what if you could create a custom
library of precisely edited cells
within weeks in your lab with almost
negligible hands-on time
this is what the onyx platform enables
the onyx platform provides the ability
to create and track a wide variety
of precise edit types across the genome
and this current version of the onyx
platform
has been developed for e coli and for
saccharomyces cerevisiae
the onyx platform is designed in such a
way
to enable you to might make libraries of
variants with
extreme ease so let let us look at
what this platform provides when you
purchase this platform
you get access to the benchtop
instrument and access to the software
and consumables the platform
enables all steps of a dbtl
cycle for instance you saw start
with software that's extremely easy
to design hundreds of thousands of edits
and then we have custom reagents and
the benchtop instrument that enables
you to create a genome
engineering genome scale engineered
library
of cells by managing the
genome editing and cell handling
processes
once you have the libraries yourself we
also have a suite of assays
that you can bring together with your
phenotyping of the libraries
so that you can this enables you
very rapid genotyping as i said before
these are
trackable libraries so all the cells
here
contain a barcode and
the barcode can be sequenced through ngs
sequencing
that enables you to quickly identify
the genotype that is related to your
phenotype of interest
and this process completes with
resolver software which enables you to
identify the uh genotype and
connect it to the phenotype so by this
combination of software instrument and
analytics we are able to create
libraries of engineered cells which are
precise
single edit per cell diversity of edit
types such as
deletions insertions and substitutions
and
enable rapid genotyping so we spoke
about
scale performance and ease of use
earlier
so let's unpack that a little bit and
see how the onyx platform achieves
this
so there are many aspects of this system
that improves the overall workflow to
make it extremely easy
let's focus on scale traditional
approaches
to scaling up genome engineering
typically
involve use of microtiter plates
and delivery of reagents into individual
wells to keep them partitioned
however our co-founder andrew gast
found a very nifty solution to achieve
scale
that will help us move away from the
traditional workflows
by covalently linking the guide rna to
the donor template
we have removed the need for physical
partitions
and can now use cells as the partition
and in addition to the guide rna and the
donor
we've also added a bar code to this
construct
allowing us now to scale from hundreds
of
wells to hundreds of thousands of cells
which are also trackable
and this edition of the barcode enables
rapid ngs based tracking which is ngs
sequencing
is extremely predominant now and very
easy to accomplish
so the second problem that you usually
face when you're scaling up genome
editing
is consistent reliable performance
a big challenge is the non-linearity of
biological processes
that results in very poor coverage
of designs or a very low fraction of
edited
cells in the library to overcome this
we have developed several
transformational microfluidics devices
that
help ensure that you have consistency
within the process and this
manages the non-linearity of biological
processes
inherent to any genome editing workflow
so what this
gives you is a very uniform
coverage of all your designs and
high fraction of the designs observed
within
your library
the ease of use and the performance
is also enhanced by our very unique
editing reagents that consist of all
components that are required to deliver
a successful editing reaction
including a guide rna a donor template
repair proteins we also have proprietary
mad 7 nuclease which is of the caps 12a
family
and we are at the barcode so this is a
complete solution
and it is episomal so it does not
require
any background modification of yourself
to say um integrating the nuclease or
the barcodes
and what this now so we we looked at
scale and performance
and i will give you an example of how we
enable diversity of edit types
we enable you to go beyond just knocking
out genes
you can design a diversity of edit types
that gives you
control over biological processes
be it transcription translation or
protein
function and here are a few examples
of the variety of edits that we've
demonstrated
the capacity to deliver up to 63 base
pairs in
any edit type enables you to drive gene
expression in e coli for instance
by inserting a promoter rbs sequence in
front of
every single gene of e coli
if you require let's say a more subtle
control you can swap
a terminator sequence for instance and
this is an example
we've shown in yeast
you can also modify protein function
by accessing coding regions by either
let's say
knocking out protein function by
truncating proteins
by insertion of stock codons
or modify protein function by scanning
uh either selected sites or across the
entire protein
through saturation mutagenesis so now
given all the diverse edit types that
you can achieve on this platform
how can you think about library design
strategies
so here are a few examples
we've worked on these strategies both
internally and with collaborators
such as our early access partners and i
can
show you here our libraries where for
instance you have a genome-wide promoter
ladder
where we've taken five different
promoters
from igem of varying
expression levels and inserted this into
every
upstream of every single gene of e coli
so
you have a ladder of expression now that
you can compare
across the entire genome
another example of gene regulation is
our collaboration with dr michael brent
at washington
university where we have edited
transcription factor funding sites in
upstream of selected targets these
substitutions then enable us to study
the
impact of swapping out transcription
factor binding sites
in combination with the targets that we
selected
if you're interested more in say pathway
optimization
we also have an example where of a
lysine pathway that i will talk to you
more about in the
upcoming slides here we've taken
the example that i have here is enzymes
of the lysine biosynthesis pathway in e
coli
and we have done saturation mutagenesis
of all the enzymes
and we also use transcription factors
that regulate
this particular pathway so this gives
you a handle
of how to study pathway optimization
we've also have a collaboration
with dr jeff bucher at nyu where
we studied the rapid identification of
causal
mutation in an edited
highly engineered strain to identify
edits
that can revert the growth
phenotype in the engineered strain and
i'll
give you an example of this in as an
application
several of you are probably interested
also
in engineering heterologous proteins or
pathways that you have
inserted into the genome of say yeast or
e coli
our platform enables you to target
the heterologous elements that you've
introduced
so now what you have is a fantastic
handle to both edit the native genome
and the heterologous pathways that
you've
inserted and we have several
collaborations where we are studying
that aspect as well
the library sizes can range anywhere
from a hundred designs to say six
thousand designs in
yeast and ten thousand designs in e coli
so this gives you a wide range of
flexibility
now to study libraries of
different sizes and asking questions
around the native genome
or heterologous pathways of proteins
that you've inserted
and across coding and non-coding regions
where you can study biology whether it
be gene regulation or protein function
modification
this flexibility and the ease of use
and the scale up is what really drives
and accelerates biology
so let's look at an example the first
example
i will talk about is
the use of this platform in forward
engineering
to rapidly identify phenotypes of
interest
and a second example would be in genome
discovery
where you rapidly identify causal genes
that control growth in engineered yeast
strains
for the first example around forward
engineering
we decided to engineer the native genome
of
e coli to test
how we could achieve increased
production
of high value amino acid lysane
in e coli traditional approaches
usually would start with only
the selected targets that which that are
known to be associated with lysine
biology
and mostly focusing on proteins and
trying to identify
modifications of protein function
what we wanted to do was to ask the
question
whether we can combine
two different approaches the traditional
approach
which is a very rational approach with
known
targets with a completely
unbiased approach where you target the
entire genome
with a wide variety of edit types
so for the rational approach we
identified
the enzymes in the lysine biosynthesis
pathway
we also identified transcriptional
regulators
of this particular pathway and built
libraries that primarily
involved saturation mutagenesis as a
strategy and
for the unbiased approach
we went across the genome and
created protein truncation using stop
codon insertion across
every single gene targeting every single
gene in e coli
similarly we also built five different
libraries
of genome-wide promoter insertion
and each of these libraries included
a promoter that i spoke about earlier
from the igem set of five where
they had an increasing range of
expression
that has been tested before so now we
have
very valuable libraries that are
regulating both protein function
and gene expression we built
around 24 libraries and
this included library sizes ranging
anywhere
from 4 000 to 10 000 designs per library
that gave us about 200 000 designs in
total
what we then did was to use a high
throughput screening workflow
the output of the onyx platform
is a tube of cells
that heterogeneous
mix of edited and unedited cells
we then singulated these cells in a high
throughput workflow
and measured tighter of lysine
using a rapid-fire mass spec approach
we the other principle that we followed
here
was the idea of forward engineering
being the
rapid iteration through the phenotypic
landscape
so we did not go really deep into the
200 000 design
and we only screened for 18 000 isolates
so it was a very shallow sampling of the
set
of designs that we had created the graph
here shows you results from the primary
screen
of this particular approach and what you
see
on the x-axis are the different
libraries
the center panel being the
traditional approach that starts with
known
targets which are all the pathway
enzymes here and
it is book ended by the knockout and the
promoter
ladder libraries the y-axis plots the
cold improvement in lysine production
compared to wild type you can see from
primary screening
already that both approaches
the traditional at the rational and the
unbiased approach
both give you variants that provide very
high titles of lysane
and similarly we do have
scenarios in both cases where the lysane
titles drop
so we know we are having a real
impact on the biology of the system that
we are studying
we then took the top hits from all these
libraries
and re-screened them or retested them
for confirming the lysane titers
and the question we were asking is
lysine biology is extremely well studied
system in e coli
given that can we identify
novel targets both in the
rational approach and in the unbiased
approach
and we were able to identify targets in
both these cases
using the scale and diversity of the
edit types that we've
put into these libraries so the next
slide let's look at the pathway
engineering results
as i said before we targeted about 19
lysine biosynthesis pathway genes
and about 20 transcription factors
these are targets that are very well
studied and we
also identified
a key edits or
in all these different uh enzymes that
were already
published in literature so we were able
to validate
previously studied targets
in addition we also identified a lot of
new hits in total we had 138 unique hits
and when i say hits what i mean is um
edits on a given target so you would
have
the same target having multiple
different edits
that gives you an increase in lysine
tita and to give you an idea of the
scale of increase that we see
we see a fold improvement from anywhere
from twofold to 5000
fold over the wild type this is
fantastic
because it helps us revalidate what we
already know
and identify new targets but what about
the unbiased approach do we really see
hits in this case
we did see novel targets in this and
what was really interesting is most of
what we i
then many of the hits that we identified
where in the y genes in e coli
a land even though e coli is such a well
studied organism
a large part of the genome is called the
biome
because the genes still uh
we do not understand the function of
these genes
in the e coli genome and it was
extremely interesting
that we identified several of these
white genes
as targets in improving lysane
production so if you look at the graph
here
what you see in the x-axis
especially in blue and green are the
different
hits coming from the different library
strategies
the green bars represent a genome-wide
promoter
insertion a hit from a genome-wide
promoter insertion library
and the blue bar indicates a hit from a
genome-wide knockout library
there are two different background
strains
in which we built these constructs the
first was a
wild type background and the
second was a positive control background
where you have dap
a e84t is a mutant
that creates the increase in lysines
because
that is a very well known enzyme in the
lysine biosynthesis pathway
and this particular protein substitution
relaxes the feedback inhibition by
lysine and hence
increases lysine production what you can
see here
is that multiple hits have been
identified both
in the wild type background and in the
positive control background
that gives you very high increases
over um the background in which they
uh have been edited and
predominantly you find hits both in the
y genes
and we've also found a handful of hits
in the amino acid
biosynthesis genes but this time
in either the knockout or the promoter
insertion
uh scenario while the previous slide it
was primarily saturation mutagenesis
so we established that the type of edits
you make
and the the targets you choose
and going genome-wide all have an
advantage
in identifying uh
great novel hits
now for rapid forward engineering it is
important to combine these hits and keep
moving
up that phenotypic landscape our current
platform delivers single edits into
cells we are working on a platform that
is truly multiplex and combinatorial
but how do you use this current platform
to combine hits
we started here i'll give you an example
where you can
rapidly scale the phenotypic landscape
even in this particular platform by
combining the hits
in round one as i told you before we
identified
that a variant one of which was a
protein
substitution and there was another one
that gave
a very high increase which was a
promoter
high expressing promoter inserted
upstream of dappe
so we chose the dapa e84
t strain as a background for a second
round
and rebuilt the libraries in that
background and immediately identified
a 10 000 fold improvement over wild type
where you had both that a protein
modification
and an expression modification with the
promoter insertion
for the next round we use this
particular strain
as our background strain
and build the libraries on them and we
saw a further
increase in lysine production
where we had the dapa edits
overlaid on stacked with the edit for
instance in this case what is
highlighted is an edit in glendi
gene that is with a promoter insertion
upstream of it
that gave close to 14 000 fold increase
over by type
so stacking such edits
is fairly common in practice in
forward engineering but what is
remarkable here
is the time frame in which we were able
to achieve this
we were able to achieve three rounds of
this
process getting to 14 000 fold increase
over wild type
in a span of five weeks with very
limited
fte footprint most of our time was spent
actually in screening for the lysine
phenotype so this example shows
us that you can easily go multiple
rounds to get to your phenotype of
interest
by combining complementary approaches
of rational target identification
and unbiased approach and use a variety
of edit types to move really fast and
scale
the phenotyping landscape
the second example that i want to walk
through here
is a typical genome discovery approach
where we identified causal mutations
in genes that impact
cell growth so typically the previous
example showed us how we singulated
the isolates and we had
isolate level screening this particular
example
which is a collaboration with dr jeff
booker at nyu
we'll highlight how we can use these
libraries in a pool
selection scenario and use the power of
the bar code
sequencing to rapidly identify
genotypes that drive the phenotype of
interest
so the sc 2.0
project is a global collaboration
to build a designer yeast genome from
scratch
so what they are doing these are labs
across the world
they are designing assembling and
characterizing
synthetic versions of all 16 chromosomes
of yeast
and they want to put it all together to
create the first synthetic
yeast containing all synthetic
chromosomes
so our collaboration with dr jeff bucher
centers around editing the syn 6 strain
which carries a synthetic version of
chromosome 6.
as part of building the synthex
chromosome
several design elements have been added
to the strain for different reasons for
example
they've created pcr tags to be used as
watermarks
to identify the engineered strain over
the background
they've introduced loxp sites
to induce genome rearrangement
etc at the end of this build
what they identified was that the
synthetic spray strain
because of repeated engineering does
accumulate intended and unintended
changes and displayed growth defects
so this is very common as strain
engineers you probably know that
repeated engineering
does cause a strain on growth
and that is exactly what they saw in
this case as well
typically to be able to deconvolute
what causes this change is an extremely
slow process
and in the case of dr bucca's lab
what they identified
took several approaches like sequencing
of the strain
or identifying mutations through a
meiotic recombination strategy which is
extremely cumbersome and laborious
finally they
identified four causal mutations
in two genes mob2 and pre4
so the question was then posed to
us as in can the instructor genome
engineering platform
enable the identification of
targets that rapidly reverses the growth
defect
so instead of going through a long
cumbersome
genetic process can you use the
instructor platform with pool
selections to get to the end
identification of these targets
which you can then quickly revert in the
strain engineering process
so the strategy we took uh was
uh to be agnostic to any changes they
had identified before so it was
almost like a pepsi test so we
took all the designs that they had
created to create
to make that synthetic strain and
reverted them
to uh wild type so what you see in this
table here
are the different edit strategies for
all the elements that they
had inserted or all the elements that
they had engineered
and reverting it to a wild type this
was a great example because it is a
mixture of edit type
in a single library while in the
previous case
many of those libraries had a single
edit type like a saturation mutagenesis
is all
substitutions which you saw in the
lysine example
while in this example we have
substitutions deletions insertions etc
in a single library they want
the total came out to around 485 designs
and what we designed was double that
number
because what our software allows and
this is a very
[Music]
very interesting feature of the software
is that you can create
redundant designs so it enables you to
study design efficiency
for any given targeted edit you can
compare between the two designs
and ask if both of them worked or only
one of them worked etc
so we created around 939 designs
and the next step i just want to show
you
how simplified the process is to
identify
the targets it took us
about a month to get to
uh the library where three weeks of that
is
getting the reagents uh to the
to the platform and making the library
takes about two to three days
um and once you get the library
what we did was run three biological
replicates
as pooled serial growth selections
and that was a week so within a span of
a month we were able to
go from making the library running the
phenotype
and then for each of these pools we
sequenced the barcode
which is an ngs sequencing assay
and we were able to analyze which of the
bar codes
enriched with respect to time
0 or depleted with respect to time 0.
that indicated to us which designs or
edits were driving the phenotype such
that the cells were getting
a survival advantage and enriching in
the population
and which of these designs had a
detrimental
impact and were falling out of the
population
so we were able to study that population
dynamics with respect to time
zero across the different time time
points that we had run the experiment
so and that within within days you can
identify that
so let's see what the data looks like
what you see here
is a typical volcano plot and on the x
axis is a log 2 full change
of the barcode counts with respect to
at time t with respect to time 0 and in
this case it's a 24-hour time point
on the y-axis are the adjusted p-value
and if you take the quadrant uh the
rightmost quadrant
which shows very high fall change which
is greater than fourfold
uh change and uh highly statistically
significant
the question that they were asking was
can we
identify these targets that gave growth
defects
and what was really interesting is we
were able to recapitulate
the edits that we reverted the phenotype
of mob
2 and 3 4 and those edits
actually were enriched in the population
which then says that by
reverting the edit compared to
what they had engineered we were able to
reverse the phenotype
whereas mob 2 caused a growth defect in
the engineered state
reverting the edit reverting the
genotype
gave us an increase in survivability
and in terms of the code count itself
what was very
uh stark here
is at time zero you can see the counts
were about 1000
and by 24 hours you can see the
increase in magnitude to about 20 000
barcode counts so this was a
a great validation of how the onyx
platform can rapidly enable
identification
of genotypes driving
the phenotype of interest how
and what you see here are other designs
also
that enrich in this population so the
question we are asking now
not only have we recapitulated the mob 2
and 3 4
there are other designs here that
do give a positive
phenotype for survival and
it's extremely easy now to take that set
and revalidate them as individual
designs
so instead of going through months and
months of
experiments to identify that genotype to
phenotype
relationship and going stepwise going
gene by gene
we were able to within a single month
identify a large set of targets which
can then
be taken into individual validation
experiments
so to give you a quick
summary of what we mean by
rapid genome scale engineering with the
onyx platform
we spoke about scale performance
and access and let's look at the
specifications around this
the onyx platform has been developed
uh right now for e coli and
saccharomyces cerevisiae
and they have been optimized for k
strains and b strains and e coli
s288c and cpk in saccharomyces
and customers can test both the standard
strains
and any related derivatives of these
trains on the onyx platform
in terms of the genome axis you can see
from all the examples that i've shown
today you can access
both the coding and non-coding regions
in native genome
and heterologous sequences so if you've
introduced heterologous sequences you
can
access both the heterologous sequences
and the native genome
to scale your
study of the biological system you're
interested in
now we talked about scale the designs
per library
indicated here shows the flexibility
that you get
in controlling the scale that you want
to study
both for e coli and saccharomyces we
start with a
lower most end of 100 designs per
library
and for e coli you can build up to 10
000
member library or for yeast you can go
up to 6 000 member
library and
in terms of performance we have precise
edits which is one edit per cell with a
diversity of edits such as insertions
deletions substitutions up to 63 base
pairs across
all of these edit types and
the library composition typically
gives you greater than 90
designs covered and greater than 30
percent edit itself
and this is across all plexity all
library sizes
and the fraction of edited cells can
range anywhere from 15
to 75 percent primarily dictated by the
targets you choose
of course because if you choose targets
that have fitness impacts
um that will definitely reduce the
number of edited cells in the library
because
while we control the technology of
editing we don't control the biology
and ultimately in terms of time to do
an experiment the design itself is
extremely simple
the design user interface is
just requires you to bring your targets
and the type of edits you want to make
all the other choices around pam sites
and
donor template links etc
is optimized by the software so anywhere
from
within minutes to about an hour you can
build multiple
libraries design multiple libraries
once you order the reagent delivery
takes around three to four weeks
and the library build on the instrument
at your bench top
takes about two to three days which is
uh two days for
e coli and previous for yeast
so what you see here is that your hands
on time in
actually building these libraries is
almost negligible it is less than an
hour to build these
powerful libraries that can try biology
um to to accelerate your discoveries in
your lab
so in summary the
onyx microbial platform
delivers a very user-friendly workflow
for rapid
cycles of learning and you can
use this to study either forward
engineering
experiments or genome biology
and what we would like to ask you now
is what can you do
now that you have full access and
potential of the genome
without limiting your imagination how
would you like to use the onyx platform
thank you very much for your attention
today
and i'd be very happy to take any
questions
okay awesome job well we are all set
pretty much from here i'll just do some
quick editing on the front and back end
since there was no
interruptions during your presentation
and then we'll get it ready for
uh the event on wednesday and then i'll
work offline with
uh natalie to situate the time slot for
you
awesome thank you so much okay
well we are all set um if anything comes
up on your end feel free to reach out if
not
we will go from here okay great
alrighty have a great resolution
that's it okay yep exactly
great thank you so much tyler see you
thank you bye